mes professeurs et mon dieu c'est bien
plus pouvoir mettre son cv que j'ai eu
une élève oscarisée je m'appelle us hifu
bhl j'ai 20 ans je suis élève en khâgne
au lycée mariette de boulogne sur mer et
je suis également bénévole au musée de
la coupole
depuis quatre ans la coupole c'est un
ancien bunker qui avait construit
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale et
qui avait qui étaient censés être la
base de lancement des fusées v2 mais la
coupole a été bombardé par les alliés
durant l'été 44 et le site n'a jamais
été utilisé par les allemands
[Musique]
quand j'étais en classe de troisième un
professeur d'histoire a fait le cours
sur la seconde guerre mondiale et sur la
déportation à ce moment là je me suis
dit que je voulais travailler dans le
domaine de l'histoire et donc du coup
quand j'ai eu 16 ans j'ai postulé pour
un emploi saisonnier à la coupole au
mois de juillet c'est à 16 ans que j'ai
découvert le projet du livre des 9000
déportés de france hamilton mode aura
réalisé par laurent thiry et publiée en
2020 aux éditions du cherche midi
[Musique]
ce livre fait une histoire très
détaillée contextualiser de ce camp mais
c'est aussi le constat d'un bilan c'est
que en 1988 compte c'est toujours pas
combien de déportés de france sont
passés par ce camp qui il était pourquoi
ils ont été envoyés là-bas et combien
sont revenus de cet enfer donc l'idée à
ce moment là c'est d'aller chercher des
informations sur ces personnes les
identifier et pouvoir connaître leur
parcours en amont évidemment la
déportation leur parcours pendant la
guerre et pour les les survivants savoir
ce qu'ils sont devenus devenu après la
guerre
[Musique]
l'implication de l'ue si elle a d'abord
été pour notamment faire les demandes
auprès des mairies d'état civil pour
obtenir les actes de naissance des
déportés qui sont en tête qu'on avait
besoin de ces informations pour les
transmettre aux différents auteurs et la
rencontre avec les autres auteurs le
travail avec les bénévoles a amené nous
l'avons amené à lui proposé d'écrire
quelques quelques notices biographiques
pour pour pour le dictionnaire le cas de
lucie et est assez assez emblématique
mais c'était important aussi pour nous
de montrer que des étudiants des
collégiens ou des lycéens pouvaient
aussi participer à ce projet
ce premier travail sur le livre des 9
mai m'a permis de commencer à apprendre
le métier de la recherche savoir
chercher dans les archives et après
laurent thiry m'a proposé d'écrire des
notices biographiques j'en ai écrites
une dizaine dont celle de jean-pierre
catherine quand j'avais 17 ans
jean-pierre catherine s'est engagé dans
la résistance à l'âge de 14 ans il est
normand il habitait à bretteville
l'orgueilleuse et cette notice m'a
particulièrement marqué puisque quand
j'ai écrit cette notice et j'avais 17
ans et jean-pierre catherine a été
déporté à doha à l'âge de 17 ans donc
forcément ça marque puisque on se dit
qu'il a faim je me suis dit que là n'est
pas mon âge et quand il eut la chance de
ne pas vivre
on parlait cette période là c'est une
lettre qui a été écrite par son papa
après la guerre vous kyle a mis toutes
les informations qu'il avait sur son
fils
là c'est la lettre qu'il a écrite serait
décédée lorsque j'ai écrit sa notice à
partir de documents d'archivés et après
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer un
membre de sa famille donc sa petite
soeur colette marin catherine qui a pu
m'apporter des informations
supplémentaires me montrer des objets
ayant appartenu à jean pierre catherine
notamment une règle d'école puisque
l'inter catherine a été arrêté en pleine
classe le 15 juin 43 pour avoir fleuri
un monument aux morts à l'occasion du 11
novembre 42 et forcément les allemands a
atteint 10 et ce genre de deux
manifestations patriotiques et elle m'a
aussi donné la bague de
la blague qu'il avait commencé à
confectionner pour sa maman quand on est
allé en allemagne toutes les deux et
donc du coup c'est pour ça que cette
notice à m'a particulièrement marqué
puisqu'il ya tout le aventure après qui
fait que lg plan réussir et est allé au
delà du travail d'écriture
[Musique]
temps
où est l âge toujours au filet d'aller
en allemagne mais alice élus
montrer mon travail à la coupole sur son
frère et ses laquais laquelle a accepté
puisque l'objectif de ce voyage et de
colette c'était de transmettre de
transmettre son histoire de transmettre
l'histoire de jean pierre catherine elle
refuse tout ce qui est tourisme morbide
pour reprendre ses mots et en plus là on
était dans une atmosphère un peu
particulière quand on y est allés y
avait pas beaucoup de monde et on était
vraiment en k2 c'était pas un voyage
organisé avec 40 personnes
donc elle avait vraiment le temps de me
parler comment vous êtes entré dans la
résistance
oui est ce que vous êtes entré comme ça
spontanément donc entrer dans la
responsabilité c'est faux pas dire qu'on
prend dans la résistance comme si on
rentre dans une banque en disant bonjour
est vraiment un conte résistants ça
tient pas d'où ça pour connaître le
venir à doha elle a vraiment vu partir
son frère elle dit que quand elle est
allée à doha et plus particulièrement
quand on est allé dans le crématoire
elle dit qu'à ce moment là elle est
retournée en 1943 c'est à dire au moment
où son frère a été déporté en allemagne
c'est là-bas que jean-pierre quatre
signés est arrivé le 11 février 1945
gave le bo de la voie de chemin de fer
c'est là qu'ils débarquaient
quand on a gagné l'oscar et que je suis
revenu en cours j'ai le droit forcément
aussi la star on va demander si j'avais
eu l'oscar en question basique et mes
professeurs il mon dieu c'est bienvenu
pouvoir mettre son cv que j'ai eu une
élève oscarisé après oscar c'est bien
mais comme ça permet parler de cette
période de l'histoire et puis surtout
envers les jeunes générations puisque le
documentaire pour les jeunes générations
c'est un format je pense qu'il plaît
bien et qui permet de comprendre
facilement et en plus on allait les
images avec alors que dans un livre
d'histoire
c'est un peu moins concret avant l'avant
le confinement
elle est vue on a fait une escapade
toutes les deux on a baladés la ville de
caen et e.on se taper un petit
restaurant
non c'est voilà le dit d'ailleurs eh ben
elle elle m'a adopté comme grand-mère
supplémentaire dit ou bien que les
réalisateurs n'aurais pas fait le film
sans la documentation sur jean-pierre
puisque le film il était destiné à
honorer la mémoire de jean-pierre
[Musique]
rencontré couette ça m'a permis de
rencontrer pour la première fois un
témoin de cette période puisque jusqu
alors j'ai la chance de pouvoir poser
des questions et et aussi de parler à
quelqu'un qui avait vécu cette vague de
façon aussi intime on arrive à un moment
où on aura plus du tout témoin de cette
période est donc on sera des témoins des
témoins donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
recueillir les témoignages des derniers
survivants des déportations de la
seconde guerre mondiale en général pour
pouvoir ensuite le raconter aux
générations suivantes qui raconteront
génération encore d'après et le passage
de la bac dans
mon père je pense qu'il sait un police
de vachement est très bien la
transmission intergénérationnelle et
c'était quand même forcément puisque
enfin c'est comme si elle m'a confié son
histoire et celle de son frère
et du coup c'est mon rôle de porter son
histoire et nous parler de jean pierre
il s'est quand même super important de
de travailler sur cette période et même
d'écrire aussi ce n est pas puisque les
mots ça reste en fait quoi et elle le
dit d'ailleurs les mots écrits saints
restent alors que les paroles ça
s'envole
[Musique]